[Music]
well the Twitter habits of some Clark
County School District trustees under
scrutiny so one of them is embroiled in
a lawsuit and another trustee appears to
have liked several pornographic images
Joshua paguero live in studio now with
the latest Joshua hello Brian and Denise
last week we found graphic content
connected to the Twitter account of
board trustee Linda Cavazos we brought
it to her attention then and today when
I asked her for an interview she
declined then deleted her Twitter
account which you can see right here
when it was active however this morning
her account still showed likes on the
objectionable material
we learned that dating back to February
Cavazos account had liked pornographic
content we've blurred the content the
like tweets are on the account along
with school-related tweets as well
Cavazos initially made her account
private after I spoke to her over the
phone today in a statement a district
tells us quote trustees personal social
media accounts are solely the
responsibility of the trustee it must
include disclaimers to distinguish them
from official CCSD Communications end
quote another board member whose Twitter
account has come under Fire as trustee
Katie Williams she's being sued by a
teacher Brett Gilman he accuses the
District of violating his first and 14th
Amendment rights in November of 2020
Gilman got into a Twitter spat with
Williams where she responded what hurts
more the fact that I won or the fact
that I'm your new boss he responded that
she is not his boss the lawsuit alleges
in 2021 shortly after Williams was sworn
in Gilman was removed from the classroom
and was advised by the district he was
under investing due to his social media
postings last year Williams was called
out by the then School Board president
when we break our policies we rode the
work of the board we erode public trust
just a plea to be more professional use
decorum while you're on social media
yeah now Cavazos also shared with us
screenshots of her notifying Twitter of
the issues in regard to the Katie
Williams lawsuit lawsuit of District
says it doesn't comment on pending
litigation Joshua figuero eight news now